all right the year is up and I would not
end the year without one of these for
you guys here are my top ten favorite
movies of 2011 and like last year I did
not see all the movies that came out
this year so they're going to be a
couple of movies where you're going to
be like good why isn't that in there
because this isn't the AFIS top ten list
it's my top 10 list and I can only
include movies that I've seen almost
cool as a couple things you're going to
happen today I'm going to give you guys
a top 10 list and I'm going to find out
who does and does not actually watch my
videos based on how shocked people are
as to what does and does not make this
list so before you start trolling
actually watch my reviews so let's get
right into it the mood head so we're
going to start this list off with a kids
movie Kung Fu Panda 2 I know I was
actually shocked that this was one of my
top 10 favorite movies of 2011 but when
I was making my list okay yeah that
deserves to be on there it's fun for the
whole family it's exciting and has Gary
Oldman as the villain it up the stakes
from the first movie to the second movie
as a sequel should do but you know
rarely does 9 coming in at number 9 is
Thor yeah when I heard they were
actually making a Thor movie to set up
for the Avengers I was like alright
there's gonna be a lot of Marvel movies
that are gonna be awesome and then
there's going to be Thor turns out Thor
is not only great but it's one of my
favorite Avengers movie set up somebody
house conflict it has family has science
it has magic which are the same thing in
this movie which is great and it has a
great villain Loki who I can't wait to
see in the Avengers it took a great
director to make the concept of these
gods relatable for people and Kenneth
Brenner I salute you number 2 AIDS
all right people told me that this new
Mission Impossible Ghost Protocol movie
was actually good and I laughed in their
faces
that's right Mission Impossible Ghost
Protocol it had everything the other
Mission Impossible movie should have had
then three came close to having third
one was good then they found their niche
and ran with it and made Mission
Impossible Ghost Protocol it was a
summer movie in the winter you can't go
wrong with that number seven all right
we got another kids movie but a kids
movie with the Christmas spirit
Arthur Christmas when this movie was
coming out I didn't know anything about
it alright it's gonna be one of those
great be CGI movies you know that's not
Disney Pixar but tries to be turns out
this was better than the Disney Pixar
movie that came out this year this year
had some good animations and Arthur
Christmas was my favorite one and we
captured that spirit of Christmas you
know that movies these days don't
usually do and it did it really well
good job
Arthur Christmas
sips in fact for a few of these movies
some of the appeal is the fact that I
didn't know if they were going to be
good in fact I thought they were going
to be crap take source code for example
I didn't think this movie was going to
be good but it turns out it's intriguing
and it's exciting you watched the same
eight minutes pretty much replay for two
hours light it's really cool intrigue
these days in movies not that easy to
find it reminded me of an episode of the
Outer Limits and they pulled it off for
the big screen five all right I had high
hopes for this movie and yes it actually
pulled through for me warrior I had
heard great things about warrior I heard
Nick Nolte just kills it in this movie I
heard it's well directed it's well acted
I heard Tom Hardy is great in it turns
out all of the above were true
statements and facts or opinions I guess
but you know facts to me this is one of
those movies that makes you actually
wanna like stitch together some
relationships within your family it just
is two things we can take away from the
movie warrior Nick Nolte's probably
going to get an Oscar nomination for his
role in this movie and Tom Hardy is
going to kill his Bane and yes in 2011
there were a couple of prequel reboot
type movies take Rise of the Planet of
the Apes for example Andy Serkis does
the motion capture for this movie and
this guy just kills as CGI creatures he
should probably get an Oscar nomination
for Best Supporting Actor as Caesar it
probably won't happen but it should
happen right at the Planet of the Apes
you rose to the occasion however I did
like x-men first class a little more in
terms of prequel reboot movie which is
probably a spoiler for number three yeah
I already told you what it was so let's
get right into x-men first class I
thought the first two x-men movies were
great the third one I didn't like x-men
origins Wolverine I really didn't like
so I thought x-men first class can go
either way for nothing else
I knew that Michael Fassbender would
kill his magneto or Erik Lehnsherr but I
had no idea that James McAvoy's
portrayal of Professor Charles Xavier
would be just as good as Michael
Fassbender
Erik Lehnsherr turns out both of these
great actors were equally good the movie
was great and it was exciting I had
Kevin Bacon is a villain seriously come
on this is one of those movies that I'll
go a while without watching no watch it
again and be like why don't I watch this
a lot more x-men first class you get
number three now when it comes down to
the top two movies of a top ten list
like this it can pretty much interchange
but for my top ten list this is how it
played out
number two coming in at number two is
50/50 this is one of those Oscar
contender type movies that I heard was
an Oscar contender and immediately I was
like I probably won't like it
I'm just saying turns out more than
liked it I loved it Joseph gordon-levitt
was great in the movie he should
probably get an Oscar nomination too
his relationship with his therapist was
really cute it was really well done and
the movie makes you reflect as to how
life changes in your eyes after you're
diagnosed with cancer like how do you
deal with that this is a heartfelt movie
anyone who watches this movie could
probably relate to it and love it know
what alright coming in at number 1 this
is a big decision here let's soak this
in like I said number one and two can
probably interchange but as I have it
number one is Harry Potter and the
Deathly Hallows Part 2 I'm a huge fan of
the Harry Potter books so I'm not just
picking this as a fanboy or anything
like that in fact the Harry Potter
movies as they are I have a problem with
because they're not that loyal to the
books but this movie just really killed
it off perfectly there are a couple of
things I would have liked to have seen
or would like to have seen them done
differently but in the end this is the
stance that good takes against evil this
is good versus evil old school and it's
done really really well I've seen this
movie a few times and I could watch it a
few more times and for me that's saying
a lot
I usually don't re watch movies that
much so if I watch a movie a few times
that means it deserves number one great
hero great villain great themes you know
a friendship honor loyalty all that good
stuff that you know the old Star Wars
trilogy was all about and then somehow
wasn't with the prequels alright so that
is my top ten list of 2011 so what's
your top ten list of 2011 make a video
and put it as a video response or if you
just like to type comment below let me
know and yes for every best list is a
worst list my top 10 worst movies of
2011 it's coming soon in the meantime if
you like what you've seen here and you
want to see more click right here to see
more even if you didn't agree with some
of my picks opinions and all that makes
the world go round
you